all right Isaac what are we here for
Star Wars the event or Star Wars park
event
I forgot us called Oh jakey news today
so it'll just be me and Isaac it's a boy
stay out at Disneyland all right we are
on our way to Star Wars land galaxies an
edge over me and escorted by Jamie long
time fan he's been like move aside move
aside I feel so VIP right now and I told
him the Star Wars music has begun yeah I
think we're here I think we are here
[Music]
from what I know so far Galaxy edge is a
very immersive land one of the most
immersive lands that Disneyland has to
offer they've really put a lot of focus
on bringing the sights the sounds and
the taste of Star Wars to us so first
mother's run
Millennium Falcon's right you can choose
to be a gunner a pilot or an engineer
what is your pick pilot all right I'm
gonna be a gunner I like the pews enjoy
moving through this line this vest right
now because the next time we come we're
going to be waiting hours maybe
[Music]
[Music]
vii Alania falcon
get shooting
go back again oh thank you get already
my arm is actually really tired from
killing all the bad guys all right Isaac
what you think uh smugglers run
that's true if you're the gunner you
really have to press the button for it
to shoot if it doesn't if you don't
shoot it doesn't destroy the bad guys
and I'm actually really curious as to
what the piloting situation is gonna be
like we should definitely next time
hopefully we get to be a pilot anyways
Austin Attraction number two they have
blue milk here so we're gonna go hunt
down some zoom
[Music]
one two three
does it feel like you're on a different
planet yeah
so the storyline here at galaxy's edge
is that we're all over on the planet of
Basu and it is a new planet never been
seen in any stories or movies TV shows
and the reason behind this is the
designers of this land on it to give
anybody people familiar or not if not
familiar with Star Wars a chance to have
an equal levy level playing field to
explore galaxy's edge what's this let's
do it
something Luke Skywalker drinks in the
movie oh and they have green milk as
well if they're sneaking parched on the
planet about to to enjoy our blue milk
like blueberries
my acid all the green reversed
oh it smells really good oh wow okay
blue milk is not actually made out of
milk we were told that it's made out of
soy and other plant-based dairy they
both had a more of a tropical kind of
inspiration in terms of the flavoring
give it a go
good
these both are bombs which one you like
better
you have blue guy or green guy all right
I'm gonna try to Cheers
[Music]
that's good definitely my yeah with
blueberry or something
Oh
[Applause]
I definitely liked everyone better the
blue one looks prettier I like the way
that one looks but I like the way this
is for you on taste
Cheers it's like the slushie and a
milkshake mixed together right so I had
an idea that since both of these are so
good like I can get smart this is my
favorite I do too this one this one's my
favorite
so each time you drink one of them that
one becomes your favorite right so I'm
like what if I try both of them good
idea how you gonna do this just gonna
hold it in my mouth okay okay okay
[Music]
swish it round
this 1g gets the flavor part really
interesting so it's the bet the best way
to drink blue milk and green milk is to
combine it together you're going to know
all right I'm actually already lost now
I have no idea where we push direction
we came in from if we needed to make an
escape off the planet about - I have no
idea where we left our Millennium Falcon
oh wait this is the edge of it okay we
don't want to go here that literally
galaxies galaxies edge all right going
back in today's May 30th where it's not
yet open its actual opening tomorrow
here by the time this video comes out
it'll be well open to the public but
where we had the chance to preview it
and this is pretty awesome
I think this is that's empty at the edge
it's ever gonna be this is like empty
right now this is kind of cool
[Music]
[Music]
good all right so we're eating the Ronco
wrap right now it's basically a
bacon-wrapped hot dog star wars' style
or just a hot dog in the middle and then
you got instead of bacon though it's
pork belly some cabbage sandwich
together in a pita bread just bite a
Chewbacca
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so one of the most amazing parts about
galaxies in my opinion is this alleyway
here or this road and it's where all the
markets are at where you get all your
trinkets the attention the detail here
is astounding and you can really tell
that they put a lot of thought and
effort into creating everything all
right so what was your favorite part
about galaxy's edge I keep the
Millennium Falcon thing I was really
cool because you feel like be the gunner
and you get a press button I never
really been in a ride like a she's
videos herself this time yes all right
kamikaze forgot I was right so far eight
times three times we require so
are you ready yep don't fight just do a
mean you get a hyperspace okay
[Music]
this is so sec rear bar so alright guys
you know what you're doing yeah yeah
thank you
Engineers automatic repair
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
skip the flight
[Music]
but we have to visit seven and that's
when it's time to leave movies here with
Isaac's rating / score / ranking overall
review of galaxies edge so I've done the
library on Islam parties and I feel like
this might be the best one doing wish
detail everywhere like a little rocks
[Music]
Julia fascinating
score out of 10 what is this
I feel like any Disneyland Park like
pretty much anywhere
[Music]
[Music]